that's right more last of us talking I'm
gonna be honest with you guys I wasn't
actually going to do a spoiler video on
the Last of Us Last of Us is still on my
mind though so I figured well there's
enough to tie a pair that my brain wants
to talk about and yeah still rocking the
apocalypse double because that's still
necessary and I figured let's just do
the leather jacket thing too cuz if it
was the apocalypse I guess I would I
would dress like this yeah leather
jackets double Firefly shirt so yeah
that's a spoiler warning if you haven't
beaten the last of us so I suggest you
watch my spoiler free review of The Last
of Us this is for folks that have beaten
the game or just don't care about
spoilers I'm not gonna go detail by
detail through the game there are a few
points though that are worth talking
about that are spoilers the first point
being the entire plot of the game is you
have to escort Ellie to this group
called the fireflies because Ellie is
immune to this whole parasitic thing
that turns people into husk
she got bitten like two weeks ago she
still hasn't turned she breathes spores
in nothing so the concept is like all
right she can cure the world one of the
cooler interactions in the entire game
is you come across these two dudes their
brothers and they're actually likable
people I mean they leave you to die but
the guy does bring up a good point it's
like if the roles were reversed you
wouldn't have just taken off and left us
there no you would have and you're like
yeah I would if the game does a good job
at showing you perspective it's like
yeah alright maybe someone did something
that's a dick move but they're just
trying to survive same as you few people
though you're like now you're just a
dick there are absolutes in the world
yes there was just an [ __ ] you don't
you can't always go all right in
perspective and then the younger brother
turns and he attacks Ellie and then the
older brother kills them and the older
brother kills himself is one of those
moments were you like that was dark
it even joel has this look on his face
when the older one blew himself away
Joel's like uh Joel's are pretty
hardened human being he comes across as
a person little that wouldn't affect him
right now he had this look on his face
like she's [ __ ] up cuz it was and then
you move on but one of the things this
game does well is it shows you that when
you come across people you interact with
people probably as a means to an end the
fact that you're interacting with them
means you're probably trying to get
something out of them and in exchange
they're trying to get something out of
you and you all understand that and you
roll with it you're like I understand
optimism has been stamped out through 20
years of dealing with [ __ ] douche
bags and zombie husk people is that for
Ellie she's mankind's last hope she's
gonna cure the world cuz you know we're
gonna make that two
my favorite chapter in this game I
didn't think it would be my favorite
chapter cuz usually in games I'm like oh
winter
alright let's let's get back to spring
but the most monumental chapter in terms
of character growth for Ellie's winter
winters awesome winters dark winter is
winter is coming the winter came friends
old White Walkers but it was still bad
news chapter before this Joel gets
impaled he's in bad shape and Ellie's
out there and Ellie has become an
efficient hunter the first thing you see
is this rabbit this arrow goes through
the rabbit and Ellie picks up the arrow
and she's like oh that's not going to be
enough reminding me of castaway when you
see the fish and a spear goes through
and it pans up and you see Tom Hanks
he's all tropical Jesus now he's a man
of the woods you can tell he's become
really efficient at survival Ellie has
hit that point now you're like yeah that
kid really stepped up and now she is
just keeping them alive Ellie plays a
little differently than Joel she can't
hold people up and use them as human
shields but it's awesome doing that
stealth kill where she comes up behind
people first stabbing their neck you
know you're like oh well you know dead
folk that picture right there is one of
those pictures I didn't want to show in
my review by spoiler free review of the
game cuz I saw it I was like I didn't
want to know that Ellie becomes that
badass yeah you see her with a rifle on
the cover sure but a bow and arrow is a
different thing entirely
but when arrow means you're now
efficient in the apocalypse so I show it
to you now best picture ever and you
come across this one guy David you don't
really know what to make of David all
you know is he's voiced by Nolan North
which is a lie I didn't actually know
that until the end credits but at the
time he seems like an okay person he
gets you out of a couple of tight spots
you're like all right you're building
rapport with this guy I mean he's like
funny thing
there's just madman out there and he's
just killed a lot of us and rumor is
he's pelling around with this little
girl you know anything about that you're
like oh [ __ ] Ellie grabs her bow and
arrow and she's like all right back up
and yeah David's like stay with us and
you'll live but if you leave we're
probably gonna hunt you down and of
course Elly's loyal to Joel so she's
like yeah and you leave and you know
you're gonna see this guy later on but
this guy captures Ellie and you can tell
he's kind of conflicted by it like look
we're all trying to survive just just
hang with us man she breaks his finger
which is also another sweet scene
because he wants her name and she won't
tell him so she's like Ellie tell him my
name is Ellie and that's the name of the
girl that broke your [ __ ] finger
that's about and I was like this might
be the best character in a game period
in 2013
oh you forgot to mention that this band
of post-apocalyptic douchebag cheddar
cannibals people do what they need to do
to survive in the apocalypse and well
these folks chose their path probably
tastes like jaren so Ellie escapes the
Donner Party and there's this whole
showdown in this building this buildings
burning and Ellie gets the drop on this
guy it just starts beating his head in
with this machete I mean this dude's
dead and Joel finds her Ennis this big
moment where it's yeah Ellie was through
some bad [ __ ] in winter so spring comes
in at this point joel is making small
talk with Ellie you can tell joel is
accepted Elias family but now Ellie's
really distant cuz it's like that [ __ ]
that happened in winter it's permanent
damage yeah she's probably not the same
person after that that just well that
all just sucked and then the end of the
game comes and this is this situation
you find the fireflies Joel wakes up and
the chick you met near the beginning of
the games like oh hey we have Ellie
we're prepping her for surgery and
Joel's like can I see her and she's like
no she can't we're not gonna draw this
out we're prepping her for surgery and
we need to harvest the [ __ ] from her
brain she's gonna die but just stay in
the cell and oh if he tries to move
shoot him sorry
immediately you understand where they're
coming from but you have a problem with
it because they're about to kill Ellie
we can't have that [ __ ] stand yeah it
might save the human race but hey
there's always next time so Joel goes on
a rampage and just wipes out all these
people grabs Ellie and it's awesome you
pick up Ellie and it's game play and so
you're running through and this tragic
musics playing and you're dodging all
these people and you get her out of
there you have a faceoff with the main
chick and the chicks like this could
save humanity she's the key to a cure
Jules like ya know Pam shoots her in the
head a lot of people have a problem with
this ending like Joel became a villain
but the game spent about 16 hours
establishing that yeah there are people
that do dark things in this world but as
their perspective they do what they feel
they need to do to survive yeah it might
have been a selfish thing for Joel to do
to save Ellie but anyone playing the
game didn't hesitate to agree with him
initially everyone wiped out everyone
with the mindset I gotta save Ellie
everything you found all the information
it all it told you was that it's
possible that they could make a cure
with this is it a certainty is it a
definite no it's not so it's not the kid
will die but the human race will be
immune to this parasite it's the kid
will die in the human race might be
immune but it might not you feel like so
much research would have to go into
studying this understanding it trial and
error
no certainties friends and well we've
kind of adapted to the world as it is I
don't know maybe I'm being an [ __ ]
maybe I'm making excuses I guess I would
have doomed the human race myself Spock
would argue me and tell me the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
or the one and I'd be like you're
probably right that being said let's say
belly you robot the game's a personal
journey with Joel Joel and his
connection with Ellie ultimately he grew
as a person he accepted family he had
walled that off years ago this girl
cracked through and he's like oh I still
have that in me to be human now that
I've accepted that that compromises my
ability to have these people kill her
and possibly synthesize a cure it's give
and take right there but the story being
a personal journey I'll be like well
I'll go with personal growth over
carrying the human race in a game I
guess you did too don't even lie I mean
it's easy to say all Joel's an [ __ ]
and he doomed the human race but if you
were in his position in his shoes in
that situation could you really have let
her die could you have done that that is
tough I'd have been like look Ellie they
were gonna kill you because killing you
is the only way to synthesize a cure and
I stopped him I wiped them all out if
you still want to do this I'm sure at
this little safe haven that we're going
to they have a medical team in which
they could probably do the same thing
but they were [ __ ] about it so I
slaughtered but he lies to her and he's
like I know there's a lot of people that
are immune and and it doesn't really
mean anything the human race is still
screwed and she's like tell me you were
telling the truth in Joel's life yeah I
was telling the truth she's like okay
and that's where it ends I still wish
they showed a little more in the end of
the game but in the end it's just kind
of okay credits this is me literally
nitpicking it's not like that ending
compromises anything it's not like it
wasn't a good ending I'm just saying if
they could show a little more I would
have been like oh that's better over the
game and the vibe it's had for the past
16 hours a game playing what it is the
ending does fit the game it's a good
standalone game if this is the only Last
of Us game that we get I'd be like
awesome we have ourselves a sweet
masterpiece no need for a franchise but
I heard that they made this for the sake
of building a new franchise in which
we're going to get more it's not like
the abrupt ending of this game is just
the last we'll ever see these characters
I saw The Last of Us and the ending and
the spoilers and all the good [ __ ] if
you're still around that means you don't
care about spoilers or you have played
the game what did you think about all of
it whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you